make down
please go
Michael Thomas
papers were rejected because they did
not bear the official mark 36 our papers
were rejected because votes were given
for more than one candidate to our
papers were rejected because there was
something written or March on about
paper by which the motion could be
identified a hundred posts ever both
papers were rejected because they were
unmarked or void processes the turnout
for this election was 58 points 75% I
now
I want to thank everybody my New York
Street are very good thank you also to
complete made us all sane tonight and
during the day and make sure that
happens
thank you all to all my credit cards
we've had a lot of hustings together got
to know each other quite well and very
lost
in joy to work big thank you to my team
typically in my campaign manager Cheryl
my right-hand woman there's a Google
plasma day today at all the fantastic
members of the search party faith in me
to spend many hours helping and also
funding in campaign a big focus my all
suffering family because of history of
very long time every single one of us my
gratitude thank you so much the most
importantly thank you
Pratap Singh I'm sure you wish need to
pass on your thanks for the many years
that Mike Hancock has been revered and a
certain local politics of 40 years I'm
sorry lose money or together planks
we've run a positive campaign and I
believe that is the only way to run a
campaign focusing on policies for every
personalities show people that you have
a plan to move forward I will be
focusing on my platter for Portsmouth I
will be campaigning for more diverse
jobs investment raising standards in
education and so our young people can
have the best start in life and most
importantly to most people
I hope we have a lot better NHS watching
easier better access to mental health
care and end the world accident
emergency and I will make sure that
everybody's looked after regardless of
their politics there's 22 I'm looking
forward to working with penny and nearly
sure the cause of people supported legal
parent efforts now see my journey to
become a member Department has been a
very old one I have served my
apprenticeship by the knees so the young
people I've met yesterday and addicted
to the people for the young people from
Portsmouth Grammar School
I hope that you'll appreciate that it's
determination of the systems in your
missions that in any profession that
gets you somewhere it's not an easy
journey but I'm looking forward to
introducing a new generation of young
people into politics that ensure your
democratic future of our country thank
you guys everybody who's made this day
success smart and the tittie thank you
to all those watching threatening
policies